you know I've always been obsessed with
big questions and the bigger the
questions the more obsessed have been
with him you know he meant what's going
on with ultimate nature reality and so
on and the two biggest mysteries in
science the way I saw it when I lay on
my hammock as a teenager between two
apple trees was I the mystery universe
out there which I spent the first 25
years of my career on and then our
universe in here telogen consciousness
in mine which I'm worked and been
working on in recent years at MIT and in
the very big picture then what's
happened is our universe is woken up
become aware of itself and some of this
these self-aware parts of our universe
namely us have become or would have
managed to figure out so much now about
how it works through science they were
beginning to get better and better at
building technology to actually act back
on our universe hey earth looks very
different now at least the Boston area
does from million years ago because of
what we can do with our technology we
talked earlier about how we've even
discovered now that we actually have the
potential to do great things and help
life spread throughout University will
help a universe wake up much much more
we also of course have the potential to
do the opposite we're on the cusp of
technology that could just eliminate
life completely and make our universe
permanently go back to sleep so which so
in some sense I feel that after 13.8
billion years our universe has reached
this interesting fork in the road we can
take the life route or the death route
and I think there's no more exciting
question to work on to try to make sure
we make the right choice in this fork
and the way I think about it is not I'm
quite optimistic that we can create a
really inspiring future with technology
but that's gonna require winning what I
call the wisdom race the race between
the growing power of the technology
exponentially growing power of the
technology with the wisdom
with what you manage this tech because
some people these days I find take
technologies to be their new religion
basically worship it and say technology
is good and technology is morally good
the more technology we have the better
automatically and but it's important to
remember that technology is not actually
morally good and nor is it morally evil
technology is just a tool an amplifier
of your power to do good or evil yeah
and that means that the more powerful
attack becomes right the more important
it is to think about how you steer it
what you do with it right yes sometimes
people ask me about powerful tech like
AI and ask me if I are you for it or
against it then I always ask them what
about fire before fire are against fire
and that shows how ridiculous it is fire
isn't evil or good but it you know I'm
all for using it to keep this house warm
in the winter and I'm all against using
it to burn down our neighbor's house yes
so how can we actually win this wisdom
race then and make sure that we develop
our wisdom for technology management's
fast enough that we do good things with
our tech the big thing we learn by
looking at history is that we've all in
the past always used this mist strategy
of learning from mistakes first we
invented fire screwed up a bunch of
times
then we invented the fire extinguisher
yep first we invented the car screwed up
a lot of times a lot of people buy it
then we invented the seatbelt the airbag
the traffic light then laws against
driving too fast laws against driving
when you're drunk as a skunk and stuff
like this
so the wisdom I was always reactive
there's no room for reactive wisdom well
if there was with fire and so on yes
there were a lot of tragedies but I
think more like we more or less ended up
in a situation today where fire is much
more positive than negative and its
impact except for climate change
but there's a catch here technology is
getting exponentially more and more
powerful right and at some point it
crosses the threshold of power we're
learning from mistakes actually goes
from being good strategy to being a
really really bad strategy and I feel
we've already crossed that threshold
with nuclear weapons and we've on the
verge of crossing the threshold with
synthetic biology which can be used
fantastically to improve our health or
to create engineer and pandemics and
we're totally gonna cross that threshold
with artificial intelligence if we
succeed in building artificial general
intelligence that can outsmart us you
know in all ways so which means that now
is the time to shift mindsets in this
with wisdom race away from just saying
we're gonna keep learning from mistakes
too instead being proactive and think
see what can go wrong to make sure we
get it right and it this might sound
kind of obvious to you since I see
you're nodding but it's funny because
people took them to tell me stop that's
Luddite scare mongering it's foresight
that's having foresight and figuring out
how to work together across the
countries of the world in the scientists
of the world the ethicists of the world
this is extremely important you know and
nor the MIT people like me we call it
safety engineering